[Music]
tonight I would like to talk
about
when you play a Swiss tournament
especially with a few rounds a day
your preparation depends on your
ah
if you know
opponents you play then it's easier to
prepare to the
particular game
but in around Roman tournaments
it's a little bit different case
you have enough time to prepare the
particular game
and you can use this time
to get
a good position
after the opening
and you can prepare
a
even
if your opponent plays rare rare
opponents
in a
2020 I played in U.S Senior championship
versus
I
never met him or the board
and when I started to prepare to the
game
I found that his main
opening choice is to play
A3 on the first move
how
it is possible to prepare this opening
you never played
you never see him
but uh
I was able
to prepare quite well
in the database I found a few games
played
by my opponent with white
and
in one game
I saw that
after A3 Knight F6 he plays D4 G6 Knight
C3
this idea is for D5 and then he played
Bishop F4 giving G2
a plane
opening G4 G5 Knight C3
with waste in Tampa
plane A3
extra S3 move but it's unclear whether
A3 is necessary
in this position and when I started to
my preparation my open preparation
uh it was
very interesting to analyze this
position because
black
can get
a nice counter play and during the
analysis I found very nice
ideas
for black
in this game
instead of Bishop F4
uh my opponent played Bishop G5
Bishop G7 Queen G2
H6 Bishop F4 so we've got the same
position as
he played
in his games but with a black Pawn on H6
instead of H7
I was not sure that the H6 bar on this
well placed here because black cannot a
castle immediately
and the main question here whether black
can play C5
immediately attacking the center and
creating counter play in the center
uh
of course probably C6
was possible but it's a little bit slow
and let's look what happened after C5
and now a white hairs
a few continuations
uh
let's look at the straight
Knight B5
attacking
C7 Square 3907
is it necessary to play Knight E6 here
it looks like black
has a better
Choice he can play 94 immediately 23 and
now simply cancel
and it looks like
97 is not a thread because of E5 move
and after Knight takes
eight it takes F4
are black gets excellent position
here's a white knight on a strip
and black has
a
big development advantage
and his pieces are very active
and actually a Black's position here is
almost winning
so let's look
what to do after detective or default
tx5 move
and now again
black
I can start his attack with D4
Knight B5
here
black can Castle
because here the pattern H6 is not
hanging
Bishop takes H6 Bishop takes H6 Queen
takes H6 and queen A5 win the piece
also 97
is not a thread
because
black gets uh
also black he has E5 moves in Bishop
Knight F4 and uh black gets very good
compensation
here and Western attack in the center
so after
Knight B5 Castle Queen takes D4
also uh not so good because of Knight D5
and uh
black gets
excellent
position here
simply Bishop G7 and he has
much better position with two Bishops
and uh very big development advantage
also of the D4
Castle
is not good because of
simply Knight C6
Knight B5 and castle and again
ah black gets a very good position after
Bishop takes H6
Knight F4 the important move
after which black wins material
Queen F4 take on H6
and here
the best continuation is Queen D5
this idea Queen A2
uh because Knight F2 Knight takes F2
is a risky
since uh White has Knight F3 move this
idea Knight G5
but after Queen D5
black gets very strong initiative q a 2
is straight and after F3 now
Knight F2 is winning material
and
after 97
there is going to move
if Knight is 3 here
then simply Queen H5
training Queens
and
winning The Rook on H1
so uh D takes a C5
is quite dangerous for white that's why
he is playing E3
KSL now after A3 I guess I was possible
because pound on H6 is not Canyon
did you take C5 again in this position
uh White has a choice and somehow I was
able to guess a white move actually in
his previous game I mentioned before uh
my opponent also plays this plan with
GTA C5
but the pound was on H7
in that position uh I I think that GTX
C5 is a little bit risky here because
white needs
to finish his development and I think
that the best
way was to play for example Bishop G3
Knight G6 Knight F3 but even here
black has
very good position after Knight H5
Breakers
Trading
Bishops dark sky Bishop for the Knight
or if white plays Bishop P5 then
he can play
she takes D4
Bishop takes G7 is bad here because of
GTX history intermediate move within the
pound
if it takes the Frozen black has
a very nice
move F6 here
again the space and also uh get into
very strong Bishops
if here y takes on G6 then after F takes
E5 Bishop
H5 it takes D4 Knight to E5 black has
excellent Central pounds to Bishops
and after case of Bishop F5 it seems
that Black's position
is much better here
If instead of Bishop takes
G6
here uh White plays obvious of G3
then
where I can simply play G5
and after Castle uh
he is
already to create
contrapped on the queen side
for example after A6 Bishop G6 here take
take green G6
idea is to play F5
and uh
Bishop
on G6 has to move to H5 and it will be
completely out of play
and then black can simply start attack
because the queen side with B5 Rook B8
before
and black is again better here
also uh
nicest Castle here was possible
after Castle
they can continue
something like Knight C6
and here after GTX C5 E5
base of j3
and ah black
can get a good position
continuing his development even with
another pound sacrifice in the center he
can play a cuny7
and here a white again has a choice
either to capture
another part on D5
uh
or to protect his Pawn
ah C5 ah
let's look what can happen
after Knight takes D5
Knight takes D5 Queen takes D5
Rook d8
you can F3 simply Bishop P6 and a black
has huge development Advantage here and
it's unclear how
to defend the
uh White scheme kintech C5 is a thread
and if
White
gives up upon
this way
taken on D6 Bishop G3
and now or
black statue his restaurant attack he
can play B5
a white case
to finish his development with 92
because Bishop takes B5 here
is very dangerous because of frog bit
and now
uh
Kevin cannot capture on C6 because of
Checkmate on G1
and if Bishop takes C6 then black
you can take on V2
here
King takes a bit two E4
is winning because
uh White does have any movies his skin
not the
no it wasn't material for example they
can be one can take S3 with threads
Queen B2
checkmate
and also the queen on F3 isk engine
if
after B5 uh
avoid at least 192 then before it's very
strong
and after A4
Trend to keep
position closed after A4 black has
another
register on move
uh basically and for example the 93 btx
C2
then Knight A5
and Black's position is almost in here
because he has too many threads cleaned
before
between before uh
with Knight C4
thread
also a nice C4 immediately with the
thread of Queen before and
restaurant uh black bishops
also reconciate is very well placed and
white still does have a
piece has developed Rook on H1 is out of
play also a bishop on G3 is very bad
placed so
taken
on G5 probably uh
about and if White
is going to protect a pound
C5 is before move then
black can continue his attack obvious
Western
A5 move
also uh
Bishop E6 is possible but day five is
even stronger because now uh
if white tries
and to keep
a file closed after B5 black
he has very strong the bishop E6 move
sacrificing the peace because after a
bit takes a C6
uh
the attack will be very strong Queen
takes C5
context S3 is a threat if
white plays here for example it can be
two
then Simply Be takes C5 and there is no
defense out of blacks attack
uh
for example
okay one
protection panel A3 and creation
shelter on C1 for the kin black can
continue with Rook bead
King C1 and simply Knight F4
it seems like
black
sacrificed piece
and uh
his Bishop on G7 now
is not so active as it was before but a
white
anyway doesn't have
any defense here for example Knight T2
simply an idea Queen C3 and queen B6
uh what to do
for white he is almost in sixth one and
uh what do you think what is Black's
threat here how he can continue his
attack
the main street here is Bishop A2 move
with the threat I couldn't be one
checkmate
and uh White does have any defense out
of this thread for example after Bishop
takes E5 Bishop takes C5
Queen takes if I Bishop A2
black audience because now
he cannot capture a bishop 182 uh
a Checkmate thread Queen B1 uh is very
strong and if an id4 or Knight C3 then
black wins
rock on A1
how what can create a few threads after
Knight D4
check take and Bishop C4
but the black has enough time
uh to defend his skin for example he can
caption
H1 Bishop takes A2 as a straight uh the
bishop take H2 A2 is the only move you
can take
G2 and now
G6
is
protected so again F6 ah is not so
strong thread and if Bishop takes F7
here then black can simply play
again H7
and after Queen F6
C5
it seems that y does have enough threads
of the bishop D5
open for Perpetual check after sd5 black
can simply play Rook G7
and after Knight S6
and Rook B7 uh
The Last Chance the last flight chances
Knight to seven and here you can find
another
a nice move
after which I'm black
can
simply win the game
if you can
find it
then you will like it simply Rock F5
and there are no checks anymore and
black
as one here
actually when you analyze
such positions you can get a great
player uh just finding
very nice moves
when
uh
you can sacrifice pieces
and then when just positionally
in this position for example Queen B6
white has extra piece but he is almost
in sixth one so he has a move here but
there is no
defense out of Bishop H2O
also here after Bishop B6
there is 94 move
but anyway uh black can continue his
attack uh by very nice moves he can play
Knight F4
and after Q industry
another very nice
a move
night before
here
what to do after night before uh seems
like a white case
to capture the Knight
eight days before
another uh be sacrifice
and black
his decisive attack here
uh after Knight B6 for example he can
play
Rook A3
and queen is trapped here and if he
plays Knight takes D5 then simply take
take Knight C3
and black
audience
so you see how strong can be attacked
only because of a white pieces are not
developed here
so
in the game
it was played uh GTX C5
and here
I could try to play 96
get in the same position uh
as a previous variation this Castle
first after 96 Castle uh
I can uh
we can get the same position but after
96 uh white can play Knight F3
developing Knight and a taken
control over A5 Square so instead of
this I decided to play a knight bg7
attacking uh
the pound on C5
and this was my analysis
before the game
and it was
they were very nice opportunities for
black here uh what to do for white he
can Castle here
or to play before
again
protecting his Pawn on C5
in the game my opponent Castle
but let's look what can happen
often before here
then black is ready
to break the center if I
Bishop G3 and D4
it is defaults very dangerous to open up
another file in the center
when The Rook can come into the play
after Okay so
black is playing a white display in
Knight D5 and this idea to put it on G6
and uh on the first side is unclear how
to
continue
the play
but
black has another excellent opportunity
he can play
Knight F4
what to do here
white has two
original level moves uh Korean
C1 and queen G3 let's look what can
happen after Queen three
uh
the night
is attacked
uh
also after Knight takes registry
htx G3 uh White Knight is going uh
to G6 which would be a very nice square
and somehow white can try to finish his
development
but using this huge development
Advantage a black
can
continue to sacrifice pieces he has a
very nice my
G7 to take C5 move
what is Black's idea let's look
after B takes C5
version F5
I'm developing my last minor piece with
a temper now Knight takes G3 is a thread
and uh
white a queen
should go out of G3 so Queen C4
how to continue
simply Roxie
that I can
pound on C5
and thread Rook takes C5 is very
unpleasant
so it is D4
and what to do now
suddenly a black
can continue
his attack obvious Rook takes if I move
GTX C5 is not possible because of check
my 22 and after Hurricane before it
takes
D4
uh black hairs
very strong Initiative for the piece
it's unclear how to
is very strong threat and uh
after Bishop G3 here black
there is on G3 a stage G3 check
only 8 92
and how
to continue of course
after Bishop takes
G3
white I cannot save the piece but
probably at the CTX G3
uh roxy2 he can Castle
giving up a knight only two but
finishing development and after that the
white has
some
chances to escape
but instead of
Roxy to black face very strong Queen G5
move this double attack
now
if White Castles then after Rook takes
B5
Queen does have a move to defend his
Knight on it too
so
what what
uh White should do here
also after Queen G5 there is very strong
uh matching thread Roxy one
and if white plays q a force and after
Rook takes B5 again B2 is a thread Rook
B to E5 is a thread
and white
does have time to finish his development
if after Knight E4 white plays
Queen C1
then again
there is very nice B6 move
or this idea of this move
the idea is just to break upon structure
on the queen side
here for example the main continuation
is C6
but if
he plays uh CTX B6 after Kevin takes B6
A6 is a thread winning
night on B5 for example after it takes
G4 A6 within the Knight
and ah black is still a Titan
and here you'll have extra piece
if
white plays Bishop G3 here
then
black and continuous Knight X G3 htx G3
data is E3
and here after a clean test is three E4
again Radian
my piece for black
because sarokan A1 is hanging
uh
and Bishop and G3 is also under attack
if a black
trades Queens Bishop takes a frozen
after Bishop A1
Bishop takes A1 Bishop takes A4 here we
can the capture uh
aid but here Bishop G7 is even stronger
attacking bishop and 8 with the rook and
also attacking Knighton B5
I guess a bishop and
black gets
uh winning position here
if
here uh
of the B6
uh White play C6 then again
black has
a very nice idea
he can simply take on uh G3
and if H takes G3 is enough then Knight
F6
or
black still has a version very strong
Advantage here
S6 is a thread and if it takes D4 A6
Knight C3
uh 92
uh
all
white pieces on the first rank except of
Knight on E2 and black can easily
continue his initiative
here for example uh after possible moves
allocate
Knight F3 Queen D5 Rook H4 Titan pound
on D4
Knight G4 22
black can simply play H5 Rook G1 take
on C6
taken G4 Queen C7 and here uh black
simply continuing
to develop his pieces he can uh
put his Bishop on
G7 for example after C3 Bishop F6
Bishop G7 then Bishop is going to A4 and
uh
to show how
he had to play for a white uh let's look
at this variation Bishop A4
Rook G3 Rook date two queen S7 and
uh wired is almost in sux one he does
have moves
because his pieces for example if he
plays F3 then even Bishop G4 is possible
Force an F4 and Bishop F6
and after that again why it is almost
entrance one and if white tries to trade
some pieces uh
for example Knight C2
uh black has another very nice throat
here
he can
just trade
few pieces and here after Knight takes
F2 and black wings because
uh Kim takes F2 is lost
after taking on CO3 and rookie did
so you see a
that the black has a huge advantage and
a white is almost in sixth one as a
final position
so before uh is
very dangerous here
and a white plate
long Castle
uh what to do after that
my analysis uh
continuous with Knight takes C5
another
are now there is another choice for
white
uh 94
is
quite unpleasant threat
so what white should do either to
hello to play 94 or to protect a four
square with F3
let's look what can happen after F3
F3
ah now black
is continuing uh to develop pieces
Bishop G7
his idea is simply to play roxies and
probably S6 B5 create an stress on the
queen side
for example here Knight takes D5
is dangerous
let's look why
Knight takes D5
Knight takes D5
Queen takes D5
roxy8
of course uh Queen B6 was also possible
for example after before
a black hairs
uh
very nice
and very strong
continuation he can play simply uh
roxiet here
now btx C5 is bad because of Queen B2
same King G2
Bishop CS3 let's look
check check
can take C2
check on V5 and black Against The Rook
on G2
what else he can do
let's look at uh
Bishop F5 move then
black can get very strong initiative
because Knight B3 move
Knight B3 uh if Queen takes B3 then
Bishop takes E5
but black has another shot here he can
play Bishop A4
and after the bishop A4 uh why it is
forced to capture this
Bishop take on S3 King B1
King takes E5 citizen Checkmate and
after King C1
black does have defense out of Checkmate
for example if he plays a bishop G3
then how or why how black can win the
game
could you find the continuation here for
black
another very nice shot here Rook takes
D3
and if rotate this reason can a one this
is a Checkmate and if c t is this three
now C file is open uh while it can does
have shelter on SC1 and green D4 is
imagine there is no defense out of Queen
bit or queen A1 checkmate
ah if
after object uh
why trades
ropes and then place
Bishop P2 here Bishop G3 is also bad
because of check and queen C3 this can
be two Checkmate and queen A1 checkmate
so there's a bit E2 is the only move
and now against three
wins the game again there is no defense
out of checkmate
so let's look
what to do after roxy8
if
a white place for example can be one
Bishop F5 also here
uh as possible but after E6
uh White
Queen does have a square to protect E5
Bishop because Queen D4 is impossible
because of Knight D3
uh
Knight B3 uh
sorry
Fork if Queen G6 then simply Rook C6
and a black who wins a piece here
so if Queen B1
white has extra pound
but black has very strong initiative and
how to continue uh with black
for the first
side uh black you can play a queen B6
and probably this
also enough to get the restaurant
position but white I can have some
chances
for escape for example after Bishop B5
Bishop F5 uh
a white
I can
sacrifice his Queen and he can get rook
and minor piece for the queen however
Black's position is still very strong
here and he can
uh create
a
attack on the kin because of undeveloped
white pieces and for example he can play
Queen A5 here Bishop C3 and green A4
attacking the pawn on C2
now
after A4 black has Knight takes E4 shot
and after F takes a 4K takes E4 there is
no defense
he can not defend protect a C2 pound
and black queens anyway but
in this position
Queen B6
looks strong but the black has
even stronger continuation
after which
King's Position will be
ah completely destroyed
black
has very nice shot
Bishop takes B2
uh
what to do
if Queen takes bittu again takes B2 then
simply uh
Queen B6
and again
work against almost immediately uh white
king does have a good
or squares
ah
he cannot go to A2 because of Bishop
Bishop E6
he cannot go to C3
because of green A5
and now after
Queen V2 Knight A4
is winning
uh
you can see one is bad here King A2 is
bad can a one
his bed also can be one as bad because
can be one and again A2
but because of Knight C3 Fork King C1 is
bad because of Rook to hc2 here
and King A1 is bad because of green C3
is Checkmate this Chase geometry where
uh
white king does have any move to escape
foreign
here then black can simply check on B3
can be 2 Knight D4
uh illustrate to C2
square and the only move is Bishop B5
but it's enough to win after Knight
takes
B5 and here uh blacks
ah black one the piece back and his
attack is still very strong for example
after you can see one Knight takes A3 is
possible
King G2 Bishop E6 so
all black pieces uh in the attack and
white does have
any opportunities to continue uh the
game
and also the last move
are here within a look at can A1
but after taking A1
white case extra piece but anyway after
Bishop P6
he does give any
a chance
to save the game
for example here after Queen D4 black
has
and there is no
defense out of
uh imagine threats
if Queen G2
then simply
Rock gate
and black audience here
so F3
is
also not so good and my opponent played
Knight F3 in this position
and this also was
one of the moves from my analysis
and
here
I analyzed uh net E4 Knight takes E4
Knight takes E4 Queen takes D5
also uh cleaner one here
does help because black can play Bishop
G4
page three
which of these F3 JF Queen B6
and white does have any defense here
because even before is bad the pound on
F2 is Canyon
and after
uh
before here black and play simply nice
three Rook the three Rook C8 with id
idea A5 to open up but
ah possession of the white skin
if C3
now then simply Knight takes you three
Rook C8
and then can be three
is design so
so
black uh is winning this position
there is no any difference even 94 or
Rook D4 uh it's not Caribbean because of
Queen B3 King G2
trying to hide the king but
after A5
white can resign here
so after Knight takes E4 my opponent
played Queen takes D5
Queen B6
Rook D4
and this move for
also was in my analysis and my opponent
tried to save the game after Rook days
before and here
I simply forgot my analysis because they
were
many continuations and it was very hard
to recall everything
and however
I remembered the idea the main idea but
didn't find it during the game
uh
here ah
I took a rock on D4 when exchange but
the white
uh
was hoping for some counter play uh
am I a main analysis line uh
line which I analyzed before the game
was Knight takes F2 which was much
better and in the game
ah
I I didn't like this move because of
Rook before option but uh
I just forgot the main idea of this line
uh here black has a move which wins
immediately
what
addressing what black can do here
can anyone
writers and Chateau what is your
suggestion here what do I can do
okay uh here black wins immediately
after
Rock d8 move
because of check my threat on G1
black or greens
a piece for example The Rook text
on B6 he can take on D5
and there is check my thread and uh
black
audience here with extra Arrow because
after
Bishop C4 it is B6
Bishop plays D5 Knight takes H1 with
extra rook and if Rook F1 then simply
Rock C5 and also black yes with extra
Rock
so here uh
after Rook D4
Knight takes F2
uh black has uh
winning position after Rook G1 instead
of Rook before uh
Bishop takes D4 would lead to the
position in the game but here
Rook F5 is even better
attack and sit a two square for example
after before the same idea Rook G5 wins
material for example Rook takes B6
take on D5 Bishop C4
Roxy 5
and now A5
and B5 wins immediately because now in
Bishop takes B5 uh
well because of Rook takes C2 Rook takes
B2
even a game
so here after Bishop F5 uh White has
another option he can play uh
Queen B5
roxied
and after
CS3 another very nice short
version G3 and this
has been for black
sorry
Rook D4 Knight F2
Bishop F5
and uh another uh very uh very nice
variation C3 Rook fg8 Queen B5 take take
and our black has very strong
continuation Queen 6 and what is his
idea uh Bishop takes H6 and black has
one more uh shot he is winning
the game immediately
his idea was 26 was the idea of q a 2
move but
after Queen A2
a black white steel has Square diff two
for the king
uh
but there is another shot black can play
Knight takes D4 here
this amazing how many uh
sacrifices are possible in such position
and now
black wins immediately because Knight
takes D4 or is bad due to a queen A1
and then 21 Checkmate and if C takes
D4 then simply rocks it and roxy2
has been in
so after
she takes D4 and I see it is good
and uh 94 is better because of checkmate
oh sorry let's just Checkmate
immediately yeah
because in Bishop is on F5
so you see how many uh nice variations
you can find even in a square area uh
opening
and in the game it was played
Bishop takes D4 it takes D4
take
position is very similar here Bishop F5
uh
was Stronger Than I played Bishop P6 for
example after page six here I'm
attacking cetus where there is no any
defense for example if a white plays
Bishop C4s and simply
take on C4 Roxy training the queen
because of threads
check
uh
if CS3 then black has another shot
Bishop Rook takes C3 Queen B1 and 94 and
he wins
between C1
infinix3 and I can can go anything
uh because
now black wins
Queen
so Bishop F5 was better but I played
Bishop P6 Q A5 Knight G4 I didn't like
visual page six thread but uh
it was okay to see it this idea Bishop
F5 was better
but even here uh
black
very strong uh
position with extra exchange S6 was
uh against Bishop B5 development and
here in
in the game
I took on G6 btx S6 uh
White just Blended the Checkmate on G1
but anyway even after
1992 here
Black's position is completely winning
after the bishop for example Bishop G6
black has extra exchange and
a completely in position
so you see how it's
possible to prepare into the game
against particular opponent who plays
uh
opinion which you never seen and uh
which which you never played but anyway
you can look at the HS database
uh
finding games he played and uh
after that you can find some nice ideas
how to play this opening and it
sometimes
it's you can get a real pleasure finding
very nice ideas very nice opportunities
because so many uh
piece of sacrifices
okay uh getting great initiative just uh
for development advantage
so I think that
this example was uh
what would be very helpful for you and
you can use this knowledge in your games
so thank you for joining us
and
goodbye
[Music]